elle a lancé sa campagne fin janvier
michel rossi investi par le parti
présidentiel mène une liste citoyenne un
premier engagement politique pour cette
jeune retraitée qui s'investissent est
déjà dans sa ville dans le tissu
associatif
notre liste comporte des personnes
issues du ps des radicaux de gauche du
centre des sans étiquette et des proches
de valérie pécresse redynamiser la ville
réveiller la démocratie locale et
préserver valoriser le cadre de vie sont
les trois grands axes du programme de
elancourt c'est vous c'est de relancer
ces comités de quartier on aimerait
avoir des référents dans ces quartiers
pour avoir des échanges réguliers avec
eux connaître leurs préoccupations leurs
parler nos projets pour que ce conseil
municipal l'a aussi reflète la vie de ce
quartier un programme pour réveiller une
ville qui considèrent aujourd'hui
endormi fruit d'un travail dé change
avec les habitants comme lors de cette
réunion publique qui se termine en trois
tables rondes sur les principales
thématiques
je pense qu'au bout de 24 années une
équipe municipale tombe automatiquement
dans une certaine routine s'éloigne delà
des soucis quotidiens des élans courtois
quand j'ai rencontré effectivement
michel rossi j'ai vu quelqu'un
d'impliqué à faire travailler les gens
ensemble à bien comprendre la proche
globale des différents problématique
soit économique écologique et du casio
la liste continue d'aller à la rencontre
des habitants en faisant du porte à
porte et du tractage trois tables rondes
auront lieu pour continuer d'affiner le
programme
prochaine date le 24 février sur les
thèmes du sport de la culture et des
écoles
deux autres listes sont déclarés à
elancourt